people used to say that cracking your
knuckles leads to arthritis that's been
disproven if you consistently crack your
knuckles you may have lower grip
strength I do feel like loosened up
after I crack my fingers is that a
placebo or is there actually any
research about I cracked my back it
feels better every time you're cracking
your back you're bringing circulation
when you bring circulation muscles heal
better they move better you're taking
them through the full range of motion in
fact that's why they crack because
you're putting them to their end range
of motion so you're kind of stretching
that joint space you're popping that air
bubble you're creating that noise but
it's really the stretching and the
movement that's making you feel good not
the actual pop